that bird also taking the field and the
right-hander gets the start here tonight
on the ground in the whole horner long
throw and a nice play
winker has been on a lot of lead
multiple hits in three straight games
winker rips it deep to right but that's
the 21st homer that also lies allowed
and winker on a payoff pitch puts the
reds on top one to nothing he was trying
to get that on the hands of winker and
he left it up
lotta was homered in three straight
games his average now up to 268.
skies that ball to deep left center oh
he knew it
dropped the bat
as he pounds another dinger it's four
straight games with a joey votto home
run
that's just incredible i mean fato knew
it as soon as the ball exited the bat
they opposed vladimir gutierrez numbers
from western and southern he's gone the
distance on ortega now a payoff pitch
that's rick right field and heading
towards the corner
banks off the wall ortega races for
second and he's got a double
here's rizzo now anthony hitting in that
third spot the homer are walking a
single last night
right field going back
and rizzo's homeart in the first
the third straight game
2-2
all right here we go again a lot of
drama last night a six to five ball game
back and forth all night long and cups
respond in a hurry for that two spot the
reds put up on the board
shift on
into right center hayward can't get
there that means extra bases tyler and
aquin who found himself in a two for 20
rut begins the second with a standing
double kyle farmer has seen his power
peak including a triple and a home run
yesterday
right into center field furious wave is
on for naked ortega shallow center throw
into the plate neckline slides it safely
kyle farmer connects again a
tie-breaking ribby single three
two reds
joey bottom comes to the plate he has
gone deep in four consecutive games
so he rips it
a two home run game joey vano
bangs
i would imagine for vato right now that
the ball coming to the plate looks like
a beach ball i mean it probably looks
that big because that's the way he's
that one line and that'll find space out
in the right center he is a hit machine
[Applause]
i don't even mark
if he takes a moment just to kind of
absorb that shot before making his way
to first base second and third one out
wilson contreras struck out looking his
first time tonight
there is the slider gets it popped up
votto down the line into foul ground the
rolled up tarp makes the catch tag it
third throws the play here's the play
the tag from stevenson he's out a double
play
oh my goodness botto was prepared as he
reached over the tarp to make that play
he turned and fired to the plate a blind
throw right on the money vada what a
night for the big fella
first pitch nice backhand suarez and
vano reaches to make the pick
eugeo suarez number seven leads off here
in the sixth
suarez first pitch blasts it to left
center field hey eugenio suarez
sacca
five two reds
jumped all over that one looked like a
breaking ball from winkler that just
spun out over the plate spun right on
into the left field seats
swing and a miss strike three
[Music]
[Applause]
grounded to bottom gutierrez works
around the two out base hit five two
through six
if gutierrez walks never took the bat
off his shoulder
big chop to short horner waits for the
second bounce goes to second there's the
force that's the inning we go to the
bottom of the seventh inning
and he goes right after him high
fastball swing and a miss
a fifth strikeout for gutierrez
half around first racing for second and
he's got a double
wisdom weights
and he didn't chase ball four
one out reds up three sean doolittle the
first out of the bullpen
first pitch pops it up
and kyle farmer makes the catch
they all pinch
base is loaded he must face anthony
rizzo
first pitch fastball
center field akiyama makes the catch
and they leave him loaded do little
dances with danger and the lead
maintained
seven complete
a pitching change for the reds by far
the highest leverage spot
the young relieving tenure as a red for
jeff hoffman
nice backhand by farmer to his feet
in time
and he walks on four pitches
swinging
[Music]
towards the right field corner
racing for third and they're going to
hold them up
cody out there at third
horner at second and here is ian hat
hoffman delivers
check swing did he go yes unappeal to
third phil cousy rings him up and
hoffman wiggles off the hook
his farmer turns on that one and shoots
it past third
wisdom could it handle
kyle farmer
a three-hit night
aquino
line drive into the left field corner
farmer
sprinting around third wave is on throw
from the outfield to the play farmer
slides in safely
rbi double arrestines aquino a big
insurance run
india
that's a fair ball his first reach of
the night
aquino whips around third he scores head
first plunge helmet free let it flow
jonathan india
[Music]
that one is crushed out towards left
center watch it go
winston will touch it all touch them all
number 15
and they get a run back
seeing that one deep to left going back
and
that'll work
chris bride touches the ball
and amir garrett is back on here in game
two of the series
[Applause]
[Music]
he struck him out
javi baez has emerged from the dugout he
is on deck
ground ball kyle farmer
amir garrett bolts it down
and the cincinnati reds top the cubs in
chicago
they have won five of six head to head
against the cuffs